when Donald Trump is consistent on
something he's consistently inconsistent
and the stock market is a really good
example of that you can always count on
Donald Trump to brag about how he's
responsible for boosting the stock
market on days that the stock market is
up you can also count on Donald Trump to
either ignore the stock market
altogether or if he has to talk about it
on a day when the stock market is down
blame it on someone or something else
never him the stock market is very down
lately the Dow was down a thousand
points on Monday 900 or so points on
Tuesday down a little more on Wednesday
and as of this recording right now the
Dow is down another 500 points today
this brings me no pleasure unit you guys
know I you know Republicans like to say
the left is cheering for a bad economy
despite Trump no no you should have seen
me looking up my mutual fund account
last night and it was bad it was really
really bad and it's getting even uglier
now so what does Donald Trump do he says
oh yeah the stock market crashed all
week because of the democratic debate on
Tuesday night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
hours after the stock market had already
closed on Tuesday now remember the
market tumbled on Monday but the
democratic debate was Tuesday night the
market tumbled on Tuesday but the
democratic debate was on Tuesday night
our Trump's followers this stupid or is
he the one that's this dumb take a look
at this you mentioned the stock market
earlier to go back to that to be clear
the Dow Jones dropped more than 2000
points this week are you suggesting that
that was overblown on financial markets
overreacting here I think the financial
markets are very upset when they look at
the Democrat candidates standing on that
stage making fools out of themselves and
they say if we ever have a president
like this and there's always a
possibility it's an election you know
who knows what happens right I think
we're gonna win I think we're gonna win
by a lot but when they look at the
statements made by the people stand be
standing behind those podiums I
that is a huge effect yeah isn't that
just stunning that a president can say
this and that there is not complete
repudiation of the obvious absurdity of
what Donald Trump is saying stocks crash
Monday and a Fox News guy named Charles
Payne blamed it on Bernie winning the
Nevada caucus on Saturday stocks crashed
Monday and Tuesday and Trump blames it
on an event that didn't happen until
after that after stocks had closed for
trading those two days the democratic
debate took place I don't know who falls
for the stuff but somebody must write
because otherwise Trump wouldn't be able
to get away with it and then Trump just
keeps blaming other people during
yesterday's press conference goes into
talking about Barack Obama and remember
this is a press conference as we will
later talk about about coronavirus and
Trump is blaming Democrats for the stock
market crash caused by coronavirus and
now goes into talking about Barack Obama
but that is because he's kept interest
rates President Obama didn't have near
the numbers and yet if you look at what
happened he was paying zero we're paying
interest now it's more conservative and
frankly people that put their money away
are now getting a return on their money
as opposed to not getting anything but I
think you know where the with the
greatest of them all we should be paying
the lowest interest rates and when
Germany and other countries are paying
negative rates meaning they're literally
getting paid when they put out money I
mean they they borrow money and they get
paid when this gets paid back who ever
heard of this before it said first but
we don't do that so I totally disagree
with our fed I think our fed has made a
terrible mistake and it would have made
a big difference as good as we've done
even without the two thousand points and
we started off at 16,000 and we'll be a
28,000 without we're going to crack
30,000 we have had increases like
nobody's seen before but we're doing
well but we have to watch we're doing
well anyway in other words even despite
the 2,000 points it sounds like a lot
and it's a lot but it's nothing compared
to what we've gone up Obama was bad our
fed is bad even though it's run by the
person that he selected to run it
everybody's terrible everything is to
blame except for Donald Trump who is
great and remember that even before this
two thousand plus point
market tumble Trump stock market was
already underperforming Barack Obama's
those numbers are going to become even
more skewed in favor of Barack Obama
thanks to this crash which I hate and
take no pleasure in I want to be really
clear about that because we don't play
those games on this show I'm not rooting
for the stock market to crash I'm not
rooting for the United States to fail
believe me ask my girlfriend she knows
what's going on with my investments and
this is very very ugly no matter who is
president
I don't want our stock market to fail
but blaming Bernie's win in Nevada and
the democratic debate and the Fed give
me a break is Trump some kind of time
traveler that things that happen after
the majority of the crash are to blame
for the crash it's horrifying that this
is considered an explanation from the
President of the United States or an
analysis to many of Donald Trump's
followers it does not bode well for our
country that the president is even
trying to save this stuff obviously why
does no one just say in the room mr.
president the things you're naming
happened after the crash not before how
is it possible that they are causally
related it's like saying a snowstorm
that happened two days after a power
outage is to blame for the power outage
well how is that possible how does that
even make any remote sense and of course
the bigger picture is that Trump is part
of the market crash but it's really
larger fears of course about coronavirus
and we are not prepared to deal with it
here in the United States I really
wanted to get more to this we had a lot
of reaction to yesterday's interview
with dr. Isaac BOE gosh about
coronavirus and we have Trump's press
conference from yesterday he's putting
Mike Pence in charge of coronavirus the
guy barely believes in science so we'll
talk about all of that coming up for now
let me know your thoughts on Trump's
stock market explanation I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman